well i think i go way back major jones  charles zone caldwell jones  [Applause]  okay yeah  ball back in the game  nice play look at that  okay look at that  it's a lot of games with basketball  being able to have that play make that  play  [Music]  harness executing plays look at that  misdirection ball reversal  look at the ball movement  [Applause]  now the blazers rhythm on offensive end  is good they're sharing it they have two  vets down there  [Applause]  look ahead to angelo ball gathers  himself  and knocks down the three an airball is  a nice  three ball time to gather himself line  the scenes up  oh my goodness score the basket  liangelo ball